let's tear that [ __ ]
sometimes I am I sang
and Dana's got a lot of exciting today
edema I hope you don't mind well but I
had chase shadowing you talk she saw
anyone really knew a first about us be
sir others what was in my memory banks
are we cook your memories led me to her
grave site ah what that's
I
I you did
I killed a woman from far harder and
replaced her
yes
yes sacrifices your talk I'm
if they knew I have done this they
wouldn't and then without us the fog
condenser might have an idea
there's still a way but the fact that
i've replaced it every second thank you
didn't seem to stop it before as
horrifying as it might be to suggest Oh
far Harbor could be made we could
replace hi confessor Texas with someone
willing aha
if it means peace this will be difficult
for me I'll need you to leverage your
access to the high you should be able to
find a spot in the bays old command
center where you can deal with him
discreetly once your work is done return
here
do we have to it would be the most
reliable way of dealing with okay okay
Texas lives in fear of being usurped by
his predecessor Martin despite that in
all right but if you somehow uncovered
evidence of Martin's imminent reacher
all we have to do is manufacture
Martin's those in the nucleus have
certainly been to go there and collect
and here i want what is that
I know what that is I got ya